all right all right
the results are in i have it here on
this device
so
the award for
most
extra tech feature goes to
the xiaomi smart wireless charging pad
[Music]
what's up mkbhd here welcome back to
dope tech brought to you of course by
the dope tech t-shirt this one's a
healthy mix of great stuff and weird
stuff mostly thanks to
this guy so xiaomi released alongside
their new me 10 ultra they're really
impressive phone that's also a mirror
they also released this
smart wireless charging pad it's this
pretty big pad and it was sort of
inconspicuous at first i took it out the
box i was like yay cool another wireless
charging pad but why is it smart
so then i plugged it in
and i started using it
and i got it so this charging pad has
one gimmick and one gimmick only it's a
20 watt wireless charger and the number
one thing it does is move that coil
inside to find the device you put down
somewhere on the charger and line up the
charging coil automatically for you so
it's this huge pad on purpose and you
can put your device down anywhere and
then you can hear
the motors
move the coil inside to line it up
so yeah not gonna lie i thought that was
pretty cool when i first saw it uh it's
impressive that it does find the coils
and line up every time no matter where
you put it down
uh it sort of takes away the pain of
trying to line up your wireless charger
perfectly every time you just kind of
slap it down anywhere and you're good
but on the other hand
that's it
that's that's all it does that's the
whole thing i mean i've weirdly i posted
this on twitter and some people said
that there was multiple device support
and i think that's kind of stretching
the definition a little bit because when
i'm using it i put one device down and
it moves over the charging coil just
like it should perfect charges that then
i put a second device down and as long
as the first one's charging nothing
happens really the only thing that you
could say is multiple device charging
support is when i finish when it
finishes charging the first one it moves
then over to the second device and
starts charging that which is cool so
regular charging pad doesn't do that so
you can leave several things i guess in
theory on this pad overnight and it'll
eventually get all of them charged for
you but it's not charging more than one
thing at once either way though not
gonna lie i kind of love this thing it's
20 watts is good enough for me it's not
super fast charging but that's a high
enough rate and i just kind of leave
this thing on my desk now and i just
slap my phone down whenever i just need
a couple extra percent battery and
eventually it'll have me covered
that's pretty dope alright so next up is
this little box right here this guy is
called the hachi infinite
m1 so hachi reached out and they wanted
to sponsor a spot in a dope deck episode
and they sent over this box and it's a
projector
and i'm really glad they did now
projectors
usually pretty boring right
but this one i can confidently say this
is definitely the smartest projector i
have ever seen so this one has a
snapdragon 670 inside has up to six gigs
of ram and 128 gigs of storage and it
runs android 9.0 but customized into a
ui they call infinite os so it's
basically basically a whole android
tablet inside this guy and then you can
see aside from the projection it's got
cameras and there's sensors at the front
and the top plus a gyroscope inside
keeping track of its orientation so the
way this thing is angled basically you
can put it up against the wall and it'll
project up to the wall or you can put it
up against a flat surface like a desk or
table and it'll project down onto the
table once you do it'll automatically
sort of start to calibrate itself and
sharpen it up and once it's done
you have your projection but here's the
catch
it's a touch screen projection so this
10 point multi-touch element kind of
unlocks this giant tablet experience
anywhere you can find a flat surface
which you'll start to realize is like
all over the place and it's actually a
lot more responsive than i thought it
would be maybe it's because i've tried
some pretty garbage gimmicky versions of
this in the past but this one is really
good basically the limitation is you
still got to make sure you're not
casting a shadow on the element you
actually want to touch so if you want to
hit this button for example don't block
the light from above it you just got to
come from the other side of the light
and touch it and it works perfectly but
once you get the hang of that it's all
green light you can literally play
multiplayer games 1v1 against people
whether it's tic-tac-toe or board games
or pong or air hockey we've tried all of
them and they all work and on top of all
that it's got a built-in battery so the
thing is pretty portable so you don't
have to find a plug everywhere you go
you can be on a train basically and just
plop this thing down and start using it
like a tablet so now you can basically
turn any surface into a giant gaming
controller without the need of a phone
or a tablet i'm sure you've played pong
before but you've probably never played
it on your kitchen counter or on a table
and then in the os there's some other
dedicated ai integrated apps they've
built with different themes for example
there's an education feature where you
can use physical objects like actual
plastic letters to teach spelling
because it uses image recognition from
the cameras to tell if you've spelled
something right or wrong
there's a kitchen feature called future
kitchen that lets you project recipes
onto your kitchen counter for example or
your cutting board and it guides you
through cooking them on your counter and
it'll even use that camera to recognize
ingredients you scan there's also even a
fitness app where in one direction it
points the workout program video onto
the wall and then on the other side is
the camera facing you and it helps
correct your form and count your reps
and track your body so really
interesting stuff that's been benefiting
from the ai engine in the snapdragon 670
chip and it just got me thinking about
projectors in a way i honestly never did
before so it is pretty expensive at the
site it's linked below it's 9.99 so
basically the value proposition is you
can either get
one really nice projector that only does
one thing which is just sit in one room
and project an image on a wall or you
can get this sort of like swiss army
knife smart projector touch screen ai
focused image recognizing
tablet
thing that you can take anywhere
and uh i think that qualifies as
dopetech okay last but not least
is this guy this is samsung's ipad pro
killer
that's being a bit generous but hear me
out so this is the galaxy tab s7 plus
it's an android tablet and so this is
the bigger one there's two the galaxy
tab s7 and s7 plus
and this guy
you know android tablets used to be a
lot more popular than they are now there
just isn't that much competition in the
android tablet space right now but this
one as far as premium android tablets
goes has a lot of good stuff going for
it like it's got the high specs the
snapdragon 865 plus which makes it 5g
capable and there's up to eight gigs of
ram and half a terabyte of storage and
the design i think is nice it's a really
thin tablet probably thinner than the
phone you're using right now but it's
metal it's got sharp edges and it still
fits quality quad speakers in all four
corners and a 10 090 milliamp hour
battery so it is not a poor useless pace
and then you get a bunch of little
things too there's dual cameras one 12
megapixel primary and one 5 megapixel
ultra wide
and they're pretty good they don't have
to be great because they're tablet
cameras but they are definitely
functional
and in fact the camera you'll probably
use more often on a tablet is the
front-facing camera which is up here in
the middle of landscape mode which i
love because most of the time you're
using a tablet like this it's going to
be sideways it's in landscape mode
samsung knows this and puts the webcam
in the better place unlike the ipad
that's actually also why the fingerprint
reader is over here on the right hand
side because you hold it sideways and
double tap and unlock it just like that
easy and the bezels are thin but not too
thin because if you're holding a tablet
you do need some place to put your
thumbs down and actually hold the thing
so it's got just the right amount of
thickness to hold that bezel and not
touch the screen
it's just an overall really nice design
my favorite quirk though is
the s pen it comes with so this is the
new and improved s pen it's got all the
same improved technologies from the
galaxy note series it's the new nine
millisecond response time all that fun
low latency stuff
but i say quark because
it's kind of like they saw what the ipad
pro did with the apple pencil and said
oh
we like that we're gonna
do you mind if we copy that but sort of
make it look like we change it up a
little bit
and so
that's how we ended up with this they
copied apple's homework but changed it
up just a little bit so the s pen only
attaches and charges this certain way so
it's got to have the tip facing the
cameras and in just the right spot and
the magnets are nice but they just
aren't quite as strong
so i can't do it blind as easily as the
ipad maybe if i used it for longer i'd
get a better hang of it but it just
feels like it should be a little bit
stronger and when you lay it down
without the case now that it's on the
back it kind of props it up a bit
because of the pen like is that what
they wanted i don't know the case for it
really is one of the best accessories
you should get for this tablet but the
reason the tab s7 plus makes dope tech
is because of this screen this is the
best yeah this is the best screen on any
tablet including the ipad it's a 12 inch
16 by 10 120 hertz super amoled display
it gets super bright the colors are
excellent and everything on this screen
whether it's videos or photos or games
whatever it is it just looks super sharp
and vibrant i mean
this is seriously a great screen which i
guess we'd expect nothing less from a
high-end samsung product oh and yes this
also does use the full quad hd
resolution and 120 hertz at the same
time i mean it is a tablet but it's
still nice to see this screen like if
you want a media machine if you watch a
lot of youtube netflix
whatever you do like this is
this is the screen you want to do it on
and it's lightweight enough that you can
carry it around watch it on a plane this
is the one so this is dope tech just
because of the screen
now it is still an android tablet so
you're going to have a lot of
partially unoptimized weirdly vertical
not quite right apps and if you're
willing to deal with that because that's
part of the android tablet experience
then the rest of this package might be
interesting to you but
i mean come on this screen is awesome so
that's about it that wraps up this dope
tech some pretty good stuff here but hey
if you have other suggestions for stuff
you want to see in dopetech in the
future now's a good time to leave a
comment in the comments section because
there's a whole wide world out there of
great stuff and weird stuff and quirky
stuff and we'd like to i would like to
feature it on the channel i think it's a
lot of fun so thanks for watching this
episode
and uh we'll catch you guys later
peace